Odin is obviously one of the most
Central gods and indeed often seen as
the most powerful or the sort of leader
of the Gods we saw in the creation
account that he is one of the original
ancestors of all the gods and he does
have a kind of leader position in the
mythology
he's a very versatile God associated
with many different things called by
many names and going under different
disguises Odin often visits human
without them realizing it he visits them
in Disguise even in the eras he is
called by different names which can get
pretty confusing for those not familiar
with the mythology and all these
different names and traditions but in
his most quote-unquote original or True
Form he is often depicted with only one
eye with his two Ravens hugin and Moomin
and has a famous eight-legged horse
named sleepnet Odin is the god of
warfare and offerings to him would be
made before battles for example
but he's also the god of poetry the god
of said something close to shamanic
practice and the god of wisdom